that's amazing that your grandpa because
i saw this video and i want to show this
video i don't even know what i'm
supposed to show you but i want to show
it it's so so cute so you spoil them
with sugar and your your daughter
doesn't like it right no they're super
healthy we're all super healthy eaters
but you know not says this powdered
doughnut going every now and then a kid
deserves a powdered doughnut and they
have to experience it and adults yeah
let's see the tube
i love it
this is what's amazing i feel like i
still get that same like whoa
with sugar it's so good and bad for you
um but i love that you're a grandpa
you're allowed to spoil a little bit yes
we are i think we're supposed to you
know it's like you you have all of the
same things that you had with the kids
without any guilt yeah you know i don't
feel bad giving him a shirt
and you're not gonna have to take care
when they're wild yeah he won't go to
sleep honey here you go
you put your time in i did
[Music]